felipe torres and his family fled their
modest farm in the rural area of the
border city of cucuta four months ago
when a group of 100 armed men set camp
there
after felipe asked them to leave he says
he received threats and then was shot
four times
i just asked them to move away from the
house not the entire farm or the area
because as i told them if you are here
it's because the army allows you to
instead one of theirs was killed and
then they came after me
thousands of colombian farmers were
displaced from the northeastern
countryside surrounding kukuta last year
as a paramilitary group entered the area
fighting with communist eln rebels
they're battling for control of cocaine
production and the contraband routes
along the border with venezuela
during the last 20 months 22 community
leaders have been killed in north of
santondo region
in the last 45 days
20 leaders 14 of them women have been
displaced this is a true humanitarian
disaster in the past the city of cucuta
was mostly spared the worst of the
conflict that affected remote parts of
this region but things have changed
in june a car bomb exploded in the
city's military base injuring 36 people
a week later gunfire hit a helicopter
carrying colombian president ivan duque
as it took off
at the beginning of october president
duke announced the deployment of a new
military unit of 14 000 soldiers to
address the situation
but three weeks after the announcement
locals say nothing has changed in their
communities we repeatedly asked the new
units commander for an interview but so
far they've said they have nothing new
to add
local officials say increasing troops on
the ground alone will not solve a
situation that requires real
alternatives for poor coca farmers and
that a lack of diplomatic relations
between colombia and venezuela
facilitated the expansion of criminal
groups to the city
la dynamica de los ultimos anos
the border dynamic of the last few years
with the closures and the lack of
communication between the states has
facilitated the growth of these criminal
activities offering them the best
possible environment for their eyes
an explosive cocktail that leaves people
like felipe wondering if they will ever
be able to get their life back
alessandra
al jazeera